so this is our charms professor abraham
ronan of slytherin house there's also
going to be a professor black phineas my
boy is that you professor weasley wait
what this is apparently our defense
against the dark arts professor huck cat
hecate he cat but it seems like we
should be way more focused on this cat
here because there's a new short clip on
the official hogwarts legacy twitter
account as well then we also found out
this guy's supposedly the potion's
master professor sharp which means he's
not phineas black which means this guy
is phineas and the headmaster nat's eye
is called natty for sure this hippogriff
is named high wing and a terribly cruel
band of poachers are attempting to
subdue him immediately after this scene
in the trailer here we totally called
the whole poacher thing by the way oh
and apparently the deathly hallows may
sorta kinda be in the game and there's
another freaking battle of hogwarts just
over 100 years before harry's showdown
with voldemort seriously you guys what
is going on honestly my mind is still
melting folks because we just got a
massive info dump of hogwarts legacy
news not really leaks it's hard to say
what this is but i can tell you this no
one expected in fact it all started a
few weeks back when eagle-eyed fans
spotted an upcoming hogwarts legacy
autodesk presentation focused on the
technical side of video game creation
this was actually a free session but it
did require registration to attend
hogwarts legacy community manager
chandler wood caught wind of the fan
excitement and quickly put out a tweet
to calm our expectations but chandler
buddy if your goal was to set them low
so the new guys could completely
surprise us all then mission
accomplished all right so what the heck
am i actually talking about here is all
of this legit and confirmed well if you
haven't been living in a cupboard under
the stairs then you've probably already
seen a number of tweets reddit posts
videos and articles about this 45 minute
presentation by avalanche at this
particular autodesk event now the whole
purpose of this event was a technical
showcase and honestly i found it all
incredibly fascinating to me it just
showed how crazy difficult video game
development really is and all of the
love and care they're putting into
hogwarts legacy is just astounding so
when you watch this which by the way you
shouldn't have trouble finding the full
video online it's out there in the wild
it's still a little unclear if those
videos are going to be taken down or not
regardless even if they are it does seem
like autodesk has plans to release the
full video on their youtube channel at
some point anyway and yes if you're a
fan of hogwarts legacy you're looking
forward to this game i definitely think
you should watch it a lot of the
language is technical and there's a lot
frankly i didn't understand but it was a
super fascinating behind the scenes look
at the game now of course with them
showing so much of the technical side
the software that sort of thing how
they've built the game they were bound
to show some new things that we hadn't
seen before despite chandler's attempts
to kind of downplay what was going to be
seen here and let's be clear here they
fully knew what they were showing they
knew what they were putting out there
and they knew that we were going to be
pouring over this stuff now maybe we
found some things they didn't expect i
don't know but i think for the most part
we can pretty much assume that most of
the things that everybody is talking
about are things that they expected us
to be able to go in and find as far as
the fan side of expectations go though i
don't think any of us expected to get
just this much information out of this
event and here's where i need to throw
in a bit of a disclaimer and since
disclaimers are kind of boring you get
to hear this one in my best garrick
olivander voice word of caution on all
of the hogwarts legacy news coming out
after the autodesk presentation this was
a behind-the-scenes look at their
development process point being while
all of the info is official it's not a
representation of the final product nor
a guarantee that everything worth seeing
and finding will be in the final game
it's not quite take it with a grain of
salt level but i wouldn't lock anything
in as 100 confirmed other than the
charms professor which chandler tweeted
about to confirm so guys yes all of this
is super exciting and a lot of this is
very likely going to be in the game we
are very likely making a lot of correct
assumptions here but just remember we
don't know when all of this footage was
created now some of it does like this
one right here from back in 2021 some of
the other stuff we don't know things
like character names they could easily
change story details it could get moved
around you may have a character that
ends up in one place instead of another
and for things that look different in
this glimpse of the game whether for
better or worse it could be chalked up
to a rendering setting which according
to former hogwarts legacy dev troy
levitt can quote make all kinds of
variations in the output close quote so
i think it's super important for us to
remember that for a lot of us fans who
admittedly don't know that much about
the technical ins and outs of video game
development there are things we may
think we see here that aren't really
what they seem i mean don't get me wrong
i've been going through all those file
names just like you guys trying to
figure out which professor is where what
types of clothes we're gonna be wearing
all those sorts of things and you know
what while we're on that note let's take
for example the deathly hallows bit that
i mentioned earlier so there's this one
particular section right here where
they're talking about building
characters so keep in mind this isn't
the character creator that we will see
in game we're going to talk more about
that in a moment this is on the dev side
the tools that they have to create
characters in the game and when they
click on this category right here for
robe well this is the list that pops up
first one on the list ghost sir patrick
delaney podmore don't look it up tell me
in the comments if you can remember who
he is 10 points to your house if you get
it right other character carriage driver
dynamics portrait armor but then the big
two for me out of all of these professor
black which appears twice and then also
we have mcmb
deathly hallows and then another
professor black now keep in mind we have
some others that fall below that that
actually have prefixes with robe
somewhere in the title so it's a little
confusing because all of these fall
under the robe category so is this just
going to be some sort of pendant on the
robe some sort of pin on the robe for
the deathly hallows and if this is in
the final game well that opens up a
whole nother range of questions because
then i'm wondering like okay does the
deathly hallows actually impact the
story since it falls under robe i mean
are we talking about the invisibility
cloak right here the deathly hallow
invisibility cloak is that the one we're
talking about or is it just going to be
a symbol and then again does it tie into
the story in some way or is it just like
a fun easter egg for fans now remember
tale of the three brothers is a common
children's story within the wizarding
world so it wouldn't be a huge stretch
if the symbol just happens to be one of
the customizable options that we can
have on our attire but like so many
hogwarts legacy fans are doing right now
i'm wanting to dig even deeper and think
that maybe just maybe the deathly
hallows are going to play a role in the
story now as soon as i saw professor
black i thought yes this is confirmation
the potions master right here is
professor black but not so fast because
there's another section where we see
some different text that talks about
professor sharp being the potions master
but more on that in a second in terms of
the truly confirmed bits of news
chandler did post on twitter confirming
that this professor is named abraham
ronan he teaches charms and he's a
slytherin which many of us guessed at
when we first saw those snakes here in
the gameplay trailer is either head of
slytherin house well that one we'll just
have to wait and see now on the player
side of the character creator we got a
nice glimpse at just how robust the
character creator is going to be and
there's been a lot of questions about
that and credit here to reddit user
andrewgames1 who went by and you had to
go really really slow i mean almost
frame by frame to be able to get all of
these tabs right here but we were able
to determine these main tabs at least
five of the six we have presets face
wear hair styles complexion eyebrows and
then the final tab that is a bit of a
mystery tab at this point it appears to
me like it's a hogwarts crest and
chandler would actually have something
to say about this one too he went on to
let fans know that they're planning to
go into more detail later including
showing that mysterious final tab my
guess is that is where we choose our
house maybe they've decided to implement
some sort of questionnaire and then also
give you the option to choose if you get
something you don't want this has
actually been in the faq on the official
hogwarts legacy page for quite some time
we get so many people all the time who
ask how are we gonna do sorting and it
really seems like it's just going to be
a fairly straightforward you get to
choose your house that is what they've
said in the faq on their website now
back to the topic of professors as i
mentioned the only thing truly confirmed
is this is professor ronan but we did
see a number of text references to other
professors namely professor black like
we talked about also a reference to the
professor hakat hecates how i've heard
some people saying i'm not sure the
exact pronunciation on that but that one
is likely the defense against the dark
arts professor that we probably see in
this scene right here and professor
sharp who is likely the potions master i
hate to say likely because i was really
kind of all in on this being phineas
black right here those three that i just
talked about were all text references
that were found within the video but if
this professor is actually professor
sharp then i think this is pointing a
lot of people to say okay then this guy
right here is professor black which
would almost seemingly confirm that he
is going to be the headmaster now we
also have the witch on the right here
and i think some people have thought
maybe this is eupraxia mole who could
have been the head mistress during this
time so they had a little bit of wiggle
room to play with here in terms of the
timeline because we didn't know the
exact headmaster at hogwarts during this
time so i think mole and black have been
kind of the two leading candidates here
black would be super fun as a headmaster
just because of how much he hated
hogwarts students i mean he was known as
one of the worst headmasters at least
that's what sirius described him as but
after this presentation it also seems we
know a little bit more about this witch
as well and it seems that her name is
actually professor
weasley that's right guys during one of
the motion capture discussions we got
this shot where you see the female
motion capture artist with the name
weasley above and then the character
she's doing the motion capture for over
on the right and i'm pretty sure that
this character here is the very same
professor we see in the sorting ceremony
as well as the room of requirement
section i mean just look at the scarf
this is like such a close comparison the
hair is very similar so again i think we
can't really say this is confirmed but i
think this one is really really close
and then some people may be saying hey
wait i thought there were many
generations of only male weasleys
leading up to ginny well that's
partially true but jk rowling never
really put firm dates on that she
basically just said something like jenny
was the first female weasley for several
generations so several pretty nebulous
way two to three now if you start
actually doing the math with jenny and
then arthur and then his father septimus
after that we really don't know a whole
lot so you have to kind of start playing
with numbers at that point it could work
again depends on what jk rowling meant
exactly by several generations and i
think it definitely could work i don't
even think it's that complicated no i
just think this particular weasley
likely married into the family and then
took on weasley as her last name and at
that point we really start to get even
more into the story of hogwarts legacy
and one of the biggest story moments
that came out of this autodesk
presentation is regarding the scene from
the trailer with nat's eye and our main
character now this is the brand new
scene that a lot of people have been
talking about i'm not gonna show it here
some people have showed it i think it's
still kind of unclear if we're allowed
to post it or not so i'm not gonna show
that exact scene but basically we have
natsai and the main character
approaching the steps here just like
we've seen in the gameplay trailer but
then what we don't see in the gameplay
trailer is what happens next and a group
of poachers are actually standing
outside this door firing spells at a
hippogriff named high wing nats i
actually asked our character do you know
this hippogriff and we give her kind of
a weird look we don't really answer so i
i assume that we've met the hippogriff
at some point leading up to this but
they are clearly casting spells to try
and restrain this hippogryph and not in
a caring way they are certainly not
treating it as newt scamander would and
then they actually end up going through
the door and then nat's eye tells the
main character that the plan has changed
he says i get the evidence and you free
that hippogriff agreed so i love we're
going to have so much speculation off
that right i mean what is the evidence
that nasa is going after what are they
trying to prove here oh remember she is
seeking justice we learned that in the
gameplay trailer there's just so much
here that we can continue to unpack and
even with all that we've talked about so
far i feel like we're only scratching
the surface on some of the things that
they showed in this autodesk session
there's also been all this craziness
happening with gamestop emails i made a
video about that check it out on the
right side of your screen now and while
you do that i'm gonna go get to work on
more videos because guys things are
ramping up for hogwarts legacy we have
so much to talk about as always thank
you all so much for watching i'll talk
to you again soon